OLIVIER ASSAYAS: I think we are
in a moment of transformation.
People are watching movies
on different devices.
But ultimately, it's all about
the freedom of creation.
And the fact that people
will be enjoying it
in different formats.
I made the movie,
Irma Vep, in 1996,
and I thought it was
an excellent starting point.
ALICIA VIKANDER:
The series doesn't feel like
it's a remake for him.
He loves to call it
a continuation of his film.
OLIVIER: Les Vampires
was one of the best serials ever
by Louis Feuillade,
who was one of the pioneers
of French cinema.
And at the center of this
is Musidora,
who was the original actress.
It is quite extraordinary
to go back to 1914
and see this character
in her silk catsuit,
and you realize all these
famous action characters,
or female villains.
It suddenly seems like
it was all inspired
from this one character.
The ghost of Irma Vep
has been haunting cinema
ever since.
OLIVIER: My first intuition
was to go to someone
who I admire very much,
with Nicolas Ghesquière,
the designer for Louis Vuitton.
And I wanted him to reinvent
the catsuit for our time.
At the beginning, we spoke with
Nicolas about the materials
because they had to be
sensual and enigmatic
and not too difficult
for her to play with.
I knew that I would have to
create this character
from a very physical point
to stand out
with this kind of costume.
I did some music
for the Vampire Ballet,
and I worked really closely
with the choreographer.
He would choregraph to
these rhythms I was sending him.
I was really honored to work
with Angelin Preljocaj,
the choreographer, and I had
the chance to rehearse it
with him,
and to do the scene
because he plays
his own character on the film.
DENIS LENOIR: One of
the blessing of this project
is the locations
are so gorgeous
that it's going to be excellent.
When you have
the right location,
the set becomes alive.
And all of a sudden, the scene,
it becomes stronger.
We did a casting of rooftops
in Paris, it was invaluable.
VINCENT MACAIGNE:
Olivier captured it
in a magic way.
In a way, I rediscovered Paris.
The production design
really helped everyone
to be immersed in
our environment.
The main thing for me
was to invent something
based on Feuillade,
but more modern.
Maybe more fun.
It enriches the sets
in such a way
that I feel it's not a set.
I feel like this is just
a part of the world.
That's the magic of
the worlds you create,
and you step into.
Sets are a limitation
of reality.
(KNOCKS ON WALL)
Just like dreams.
OLIVIER: Whatever I write,
to me, is the starting point.
I don't want to hear the pages
of my screenplay turning,
I want to be the first viewer
of something we are
inventing together.
♪ (DRAMATIC VIOLIN
MUSIC PLAYS) ♪